so now we resume our morning session and
Henry will continue our discovery and
now we will give a few glimpses so this
is part two of the talk back into
rigidity so testing for for many qubits
so I described one test which is this
simple repeated Magic Square game you
play it n times very nice it certifies
to EPR pairs and on every EPR pair
you're performing X and Z poly
measurements but what are some of the
other parameters well you know in this
in this particular protocol the the
message length the question-and-answer
lengths are order n bits right because
you copies of this Magic Square game and
also we kind of talked about this you
know what is the robustness of this game
as far as we can as far as we know so if
you're winning with 1 minus epsilon
probability in this repeated game then
we can only guarantee that your n
squared square root Upsilon close to
this ideal strategy and this is not very
good because know the more EPR pairs
you're trying to certify in order to
guarantee anything your winning
probability has to get closer and closer
to one oh good so it means that that the
technical definition is that you know
they have some common strategy so they
share some state they have some
measurement operators it means that
there's some change of basis
local change of basis such that under
that change it is in Euclidean distance
close to say EPR pairs to any PR pairs
that the measurement operators are this
close to the poly the actual poly
operators
I mean operationally it says that you
cannot distinguish between the two oh
the it's technically in terms of its a
state dependent distance so their action
on the state alright so you can hope is
there a better test for for many qubits
that's more robust maybe you know
shorter question-and-answer lengths and
it turns out that there is and and this
is the state of the art this is the
quantum low degree test invented by
Natarajan and vidiq and parameters are
much better it certifies any PR pairs
okay also X and Z poly measurements on
those AP are pairs and now the question
answer lengths are exponentially better
their poly log n bits long okay so very
short and the robustness is also much
better if you're winning with
probability one minus Epsilon then the
closeness guarantee is only a function
of Epsilon there's no independence so
it's epsilon to alpha or alpha is some
constant like 1 over 8 or something
close to the textbook strategy this is
very nice that means the more EPR pairs
you want to certify you don't pay any
price in terms of the robustness and
this is sort of the frontier and I
mentioned earlier that whenever we had
in advance in proving a better rigidity
result we get better multi proving
protocols
let me actually to sort of I won't
describe and you know what's what this
test fully looks like but to give you
sort of an idea it actually relies on
something from a classical theoretical
computer science in a very important way
it's something called the classical low
degree test and this is somewhat
fascinating because this was invented
and in a way before we started thinking
about quantum multi proof of proofs and
it's a protocol with what I'll call
classical rigidity so so here now we're
going to think about the classical
setting there's no entanglement provers
are deterministic yet there's still some
notion in which we can enforce structure
on the behavior this classical Modi true
test is crucial on something called
propolis legally checkable proof sort of
pcps
and and what is this test trying to do
it's trying to test whether the
responses of the provers are consistent
with a low degree polynomial in
particular a low degree polynomial over
some finite field variables so what does
this test look like well you know we
have these two boxes we're no longer
sharing entanglement
they're just deterministic and we're
thinking about vector spaces over this
finite field after that so here's what
the verifier does it picks a random
point x and f to the m okay it's gonna
send it to one of these boxes and then
it's going to pick a line l that goes
through this point and send this line to
the other box this box doesn't know what
line L is and that box doesn't know what
point X is and the prover a will respond
with some f of X f is some arbitrary
function that we're trying to determine
if it's close to a low degree polynomial
and the proof or bead will respond with
a univariate polynomial along this line
upon them and think of D is very small
some three and they give these responses
so this is a value in this finite field
and that's going R sub L is a the
provers win if when you evaluate this
univariate polynomial at the point X it
agrees with the response of the first
proven this is the classical low degree
test well what do we know about it okay
so so what is this R sub L you know
supposed to be if F is indeed a low
degree polynomial it should be the
restriction of F along this line so
here's the amazing classical rigidity
theorem if these classical approvers win
with probability greater than 1 minus
Epsilon
then in fact this function f right this
the responses of this black box is going
to be close to a degree D polynomial and
this is somewhat amazing because it's an
extremely efficient test for structure
so if you think about the description of
this multivariate degree polynomial how
many degrees of freedom are there well
it's it's given by this binomial
coefficient and if you think of m and D
as growing parameters then this is
something that's exponential and M so
that's sort of the description length of
this low degree polynomial but you know
as a verifier we're ascertaining that it
has this low degree structure just using
very short messages you know to describe
this point X you only need log f bits of
information and not much more also to
describe this line so so the verifier is
only seeing very small glimpses of of
this function f yet it's by playing this
game it's able to determine that
globally it has this low degree
structure
does the of epsilon depend on like the
field size and beat oh yeah I think
there's some little order terms and ID
over Q is it's very small then like sort
of going to zero then
so this is the classical low degree test
and you know is very important in
classical complexity theory and it turns
out that we can use the same idea you
know even though this is a purely
classical result we can use it to
establish structure very efficiently in
the quantum setting and this is what's
used for the quantum low-degree test
right so Oh even before that so imagine
we play this the same classical test or
you know X and L we give it to these two
boxes but now we assume that you know
now the provers can be quantum they
share quantum state so this this box is
no longer deterministic and it's making
some measurement on some state to
produce its answer we can still say
something very interesting about their
behavior this is the the quantum
analysis of the classical interview test
so if the provers are winning with high
probability then in in some sense that I
won't make formal here their
measurements are actually consistent
with produce degree D so roughly
speaking you know however these quantum
boxes are behaving you can think of them
as having some degree D polynomial in
mind so this this classical rigidity
phenomenon persists even in the presence
of entanglement
so it's something really remarkable
about this
you might have said it previously I
might have missed it you just comment on
the house though oh I think of it I'm
not sure what the consonant it's like
1/8 or something okay oh no just over
fine I feel I mean so here I mean these
responses are still finite field
elements and we're trying to determine
if not from X to a evaluating a low
degree polynomial FX but you're saying
to me the responses are not
deterministic at least for X okay so
what's really it's saying it's saying
that without loss of generality the
strategy looks like this
the provers ignore their inputs they
make some measurement on say some state
from this measurement they extract a
description of a low degree polynomial F
then and then they evaluate their
questions at that low degree polynomial
so it's sort of like they first use
shared randomness to get a low degree
polynomial and then they ignore all
their quantumness and just play with
that
such as I mean this accused the
entangled state just like all those like
corner fingerprinting does to replace
shared randomness in the simultaneous
message passing protocol one can often
use share and replace yet randomness
with an entangled state was what Harry
Bremen and and Ronald amorphous another
example of that like the opposite it
would say if they had an entangled state
they're not using it for any real
quantum reason they might as well just
have used shared randomness oh I see
interesting when in this game there's
almost I mean morally speaking
randomness and that's essentially what
the this is saying oh and that cannot
happen by the old low degree that's not
nice and that's that yes I guess you're
you take whatever strategy they haven't
and you extract like this other strategy
that is much simpler
it's this is really a remarkable thing
that even you know you can first
classically that you can establish so
structure and even when they prove it
are quantumly you can still say
something so this is the classical motor
B test and now how do you go from this
classical to quantum low degree test
well I'll just give you sort of like a
very impressionistic picture so here we
want to certify not a low degree
polynomial but the fact that these two
boxes share many EPR pairs so very
roughly the verifier will perform the
classical low degree test in two
different basis complimentary basis back
Z basis I'm gonna play the next basis
let's play the classical a boob test or
maybe I'll play the Z basis and play the
motor view test but now we have to
relate the two and this is where we use
the magic square game to actually tie
these two bases together turns out that
you can do this and this is enough to
certify many EPR pairs very efficiently
I won't say much more
so we have this quantity of your test is
very efficient now what can we use it to
do so so now I'll turn to the complexity
of interactive proofs with entangled
provers back in this interactive proof
setting and recall that the provers want
to convince this the verifier of some
statement X and this is probably due to
primes some circuit what sorts of
statements can be verified using a multi
proof or protocol with entangled provers
here we're going to make no assumption
on the complexity of the provers right
there allowed to be as powerful as they
want they can solve even unsolvable
problems we grant them that the
constraint is that they must obey
quantum mechanics and they cannot
communicate with each other and we want
to have a protocol that's complete and
sound as usual so classically you know
this question is you know people thought
about this in the classical setting if
we had two classic approvers and we can
describe the set of problems that can be
verified in this model as MIP we think
of the costco provers as deterministic
and one of the gems of complexity theory
is this result of the by fort now and
wound we showed that class of problems
that you can solve in this model is that
you can verify in this model is that
exactly
NX non-deterministic exponential time so
you know if you're not a complexity
theorist it means that you can check
pretty extraordinary statements a
polynomial time verifier can check
whether some Turing machine outputs 42
after taking exponentially many steps so
clearly this polynomial time verifier
can't check this on its own but by
interacting with these troopers that it
can check such a thing
only two and so three doesn't help three
doesn't help and but it's important that
it be interactive so more than one round
one rounds enough I think there's even
there's a paper called like to prove
errs one round zero knowledge you know
it's a magical thing but we're just
imagine come from it comes from this
classical low degree test so so this is
a you know a jam it led to many many
things in here UPC peas so now back to
the quantum case these two provers share
entanglement we denote the class mi P
star right this is a set of problems
that can be verified in this model how
do these two models compare what is the
relative power between mi PA versus mi P
star so so you know to do this
comparison let's first think about you
know the classical M IP protocol to
verify some statement X right that a
protocol that you know by for now loon
came up with so if in within tango
progress if we ran this classical
protocol then if X is true then we have
no problem
these provers can just ignore the fact
that they were quantum just behave the
same way that classical provers did and
and just prove to the verifier that X is
in each so that's not a problem but what
about if X is false so in the classical
setting you know BFL proved that the
verifier rejects all classical provers
with high positive
what about entangle provers maybe
there's some correlations that this
entangle state could allow the provers
responses that you know fools the
verifier and this is something that
we're worried about whether the soundest
condition is preserved
so a priori the soundness of these
classical protocols may no longer hold
against entangled provers so the first
breakthrough about MIP star came in 2012
by EO vidiq and they showed that
soundness can be preserved at least all
problems that can be verified in the
classical case no EDX can also be
verified in with and the way they did it
was actually they they looked at this
protocol of the vie for non wound and
they said it's still safe against
entangled provers right and it comes
from this that's guarantee about the
classical loaded pretest I sort of told
you that if you play this load of your
test there's no reason for the provers
to use entanglement that end and you
argue that this bfl protocol is still
sound
pers cannot trick a verifier so shot is
that entanglement cannot reduce the
complexity of multi
like 2018 oh they go hand in hand oh I
see
so this 2012 result proved qualitatively
weaker like had more approvers and
parameters were worse this 2018 result
that sort of proves the to prove our
version of the classical degree test
so it cannot reduce the complexity now
you you can ask what can entanglement
expand the complexity of mi Peas
this is where things get really fun
another way of thinking about this
question is are there any algorithmic
upper bounds on on mi P star what does
this mean well as a comparison let's
think about the the argument in the
classical case classical mi p has an
algorithmic upper bound right a crude
upper bound is any problem that you can
verify in mi p you can solve in doubly
exponential time so here's a computer it
gets some statement as X true and all we
know about X is that it's some statement
that could have been verified in the
classical mi p setting this computer
doesn't have access to prove her so it
just has to solve it itself what it does
that it sort of simulates in its head
this M IP protocol right it's going to
enumerate over all possible provers
deterministic provers and calculate the
acceptance probability of the verifier
and it uses the completeness and
soundness guarantees of the original
classical IP protocol to figure out
whether X is true or not so if X is true
then there eventually will hit upon some
provers that caused this verifier to
accept otherwise and you know this takes
only doubly exponential time
so it seems potentially
non-deterministic so why doesn't this
work for MIP star well when you're
thinking about quantum provers what does
it mean to enumerate overall prover
strategies well you have to enumerate
over all possible cots all possible
measurements you know first of all this
space is infinite but you know moreover
it's not infinite just because it's a
continuous space but you know how many
cubits of entanglement would the optimal
approvers need cubed 1700 oper airy
there's no finite upper bound on the
amount of entanglement needed refers to
this
and in fact the you know because of this
reason there is no reasonable upper
bounds known on the power of MIP star
there's no algorithm that could so the
best upper bound that one can places are
e which is stands for the class of
recursively enumerable languages and
this is a class that includes the
halting problem for example so if you
can solve the halting problem then you
can solve problems in MIP star the
result that we recently announced is in
fact this upper bound is tight every
problem that in re
between the halting problem can be
verified so you know so it gives an
explanation for why people failed to
find an algorithmic upper bound for this
class you know so what are the
complexity theoretic implications of
this it's kind of crazy you know if you
have a classical polynomial time
verifier interacting with entangling
provers it can verify statements like
some Turing machine M eventually halts
you know we don't know when it halts but
if it does eventually halt the provers
can prove this to the verifier and this
also means that there's no computable
upper bound on the amount of
entanglement needed to in general MIP
start protocols
okay so so how is this possible
well I'll describe sort of you know a
result from last year which really
contains essential not a Russian and
right
the result that non-deterministic doubly
exponential time leaks is contained an
MIP star and this result shows how
verifier you know this Paula moment I'm
very far can use entangle provers to its
advantage and the key idea is course to
use rigidity to force provers to
simulate an exponentially large
verification protocol okay so how does
that result work I'm gonna give sort of
a sketch of it you know our goal is oh
suppose your goal was this you want to
verify some statement X a Turing machine
M halts after 2 to the N steps just
exponential time this statement X is a
next Ament so using the results of Ito
vidiq from 2012 this means that there's
an MIP star protocol as one round the
verifier runs in polynomial and end time
and based on the classical low degree
test you know this from 2012 all right
now what if you're more ambitious you
want to verify a harder statement we're
gonna verify that a Turing machine M
halts after 2 to the 2 to the N steps
well just almost trivially I mean what's
the difference between 2 to the N and 2
to the N and we can just replace we can
just use the same protocol from before
I'm gonna call it protocol P big it's
one round the verifier now runs in 2 to
the end time I'm just sort of blowing up
the air fire
of course the verifier doesn't have this
much time to run in your life well we
want is a protocol piece small that
verifies the same statement using a
polynomial time verifier so those how do
we do this well it goes in two steps
there's a question-and-answer reduction
so we start with the big protocol takes
a long time to run and the questions and
answers are you know exponentially long
the first step is to reduce the size of
the questions so we're gonna get an
intermediate protocol P int the
questions are shrunk down to polynomial
size the answers are still really large
let me do a second step where we shrink
the answers so questions and answers are
both polynomial time this is our final
protocol P so those are the two steps
good question so P big doesn't actually
capture I mean remember we're trying to
verify whether a 2 to the 2 to the N
yeah computation halts so there's not
even enough time you know the answers
won't specify all of that and you're
only getting these small views into it
but you're using this PCP like
okay so so how do we do this first step
how do we reduce the question size this
big protocol relies on the classical
loaded retest provers NP big it's going
to get a point and a line these the
description on this point in mine are
exponentially large right so we're going
to create an intermediate protocol P end
where instead of us you know generating
where the verity instead of the verifier
generating this point and line by itself
it's going to ask the provers to do it
for the verifier so it's going to run
some protocol using very short questions
and it's going to ask the protocols hey
not only do I want you to answer you
know come up with an answer I want you
to generate the question yourself I
don't have enough time to do it why
don't you do it for me and this is a
technique that you know Natarajan and
Wright called introspection right you're
getting the approvers to ask themselves
the questions of course why would you
know the provers cooperate with you you
know they this is where the magic
happens so this is how this
introspection protocol works PN well
probably half you run this quantum
low-degree test you ask you know you
certify that they have exponentially
many EPR pairs but since the quantum
motor your test is so efficient the the
sizes of the questions needed to run
this protocol or only polynomial length
so you can do that efficiently so you
run this quantum motive you test you
know what they're doing you know they
have these many pairs and then with
probability 1/2 you're gonna run this
introspection protocol you're gonna run
some you know interesting procedure to
ask the provers to sample from this
point and line distribution the same
distribution has occurred in this
original p big and then you say well
once you've sampled these questions
answer those questions exponentially
many be affairs
that's the principle it could we could
have had many more but the protocol
actually yeah so you could have many
more but you don't know anything about
it this is to establish the here some
structure yeah so the answers are still
very large yeah we just want to reduce
the question size mister it's clear to
me our Peoria that these two are
indistinguishable they still need to be
right to the provers so that is with
probably one half you do have a law
degree test and it should be
indistinguishable from the introspection
protocol right but the introspection
protocol has different outputs oh great
yeah so I'm glossing there is a way to
interleave the two protocols so that
they're indistinguishable at the right
moments so you can sort of imagine that
there's a similar way you can sort of I
mean actually there's several
intermediate games that you use to this
game from one perspective from one
provers perspective this is
indistinguishable from one game and then
did you give us any details on how the
introspection keeping the car honest no
I'm gonna give fortunately new details
about that a lot of cleverness in there
many PR pairs the power pairs are going
to be the source of randomness to
generate these this XML according to the
right distribution yeah it's very
challenging to somehow force these
provers to really sample you know you
want to say that this proved only
samples X and learns nothing about L
right even though they're using the
shared EPR pairs so you have to somehow
force this prove err to not learn
anything about L you have to design a
protocol to do that
but in the end they do get this exit
that only gets out and then they
responded and this is the fact that this
works is really miraculous I mean this
at least the solution we know of today
on how to do this really relies on the
special structure of this point line
distribution if it was some other test
used in this classical MIP protocol it's
not clear we would have been able to get
the provers to do this introspection so
there's something really remarkable you
know maybe you know we're lucky or
something this works because of using
this point line distribution good so
this goes back to this you know how do
you tie together the quantum low-degree
test with this introspection so there's
many more tests right but the
introspection one wants to get to that
point you sort of trust that the
approvers are doing the right thing and
it's sort of how did you get from
enforcing that they're doing X's e
measurements on the EPR pairs to doing
the right thing and that's what all the
intermediate tests which one foothold
and then
it's only one round here don't worry
it's all gonna be one round yeah okay so
good so we've done this question
reduction now we have to shrink the
answers and here I'm just gonna go
through it at light speed I'm not gonna
explain anything there's the final piece
small protocol instead of giving this X
a and L are I'm gonna give these short
polynomial size proofs that they would
have given you the right answers so they
give these these short proofs these
proofs are based on the things I
mentioned earlier these PCPs
they're sure you can verify them
efficiently and essentially what's
happening is this you know the the
verifier doesn't have enough time to
check this XA and L are it says well you
know provers just proved to me that I
would have accepted if I had the time so
there's another trick in which we
actually before the step we we asked one
proven to play the role of two
this proved ernow knows the full
statement
we've shrunk the questions we've shown
to answer that and now we have our
polynomial time protocol that but we
verified this incredibly complicated
statement this Turing machine accepts
after W exponential time
kappa really well how'd what's the
foundation it says quantum low degree
test you're using this introspection
protocol to certify sampling from an
exponentially large classical low degree
test okay so you know just you know to
put in terms of pictures here's the
schematic we have this poly unten
verifier we run this quantum load of
your test to certify exponentially many
EPR pairs and these EPR pairs are
generating questions for this point and
line distribution and if this point in
line distribution is used to certify
that there exists some doubly
exponential size low degree polynomial
out there what do i mean by out there
like out there as in it's this low
degree polynomial is encoding the answer
to our our computation so that's in one
you know picture how you know Niek is
included in my p star so why not iterate
this this process why just stop there
and indeed a quantum loader you test and
get the provers to generate the
questions for another version in a round
of the low degree test and have them
answer that and just continue this
certify that the provers had more and
more and more and more dpr pairs you can
recursively iterate this introspection
technique
and it yields an MIP star protocol for
verifying the halting problem the
sounder settle for antiques further
right he's a constant but we can reduce
the Sunnis are using parallel repetition
because we're only doing with constant
so when you just served by myself when
you have to say the whole thing problem
pretty example wait we don't specify an
upper bound on the running track right
so like yeah exactly they Powell how do
you how this is improver sorry how does
the verifier even decide how many
iterations it doesn't says provers
figure it out for me how many iterations
it's one rep right that means because
the number of iterations could be you
know some crazy busy beaver but through
these pc peas they sort of prove that
each
two rounds of iteration I don't have a
good answer try to describe to you the
other level we're testing the right
thing sort of like and actually that's a
good way it's like an inductive thing
you're sort of testing that they could
have proved that all the previous levels
were properly tested
it's singly so that actually gives us
sort of a tight so if you limit the
provers to sharing you know q cubits
then two to the Q cubits then Q cubits
then they can do n time to do the Q big
but that's sort of the general gist and
it's very interesting that that you know
this this undecidability or a nun
computability result has a very
interesting consequences I mean not only
for complexity theory contains
undecidable problems but also some other
problems and seemingly just different
areas such as mathematical physics
there's something known as Saracens
problems and so this there was this open
problem called the Khan embedding
problem of operator algebras and this
complexity result actually shows that
the answer to these two questions as ago
and I guess yeah I won't have time to
really go too much into it but I'll sort
of there's these three problems and one
of them is been around for quite some
time and other to a more recent but they
all are very closely connected
so this Khan embedding problem it's from
pure mathematics and you know the formal
statement is this says do all separable
type tou1 factors embedded and ultra
power of the hyper finite so it's some
statement about von Oy man algebra is
very deep and over the years people have
discovered that this question is
equivalent to many other questions in
mathematics they have nothing
seemingly nothing to do with operator
algebras
one of the equivalent formulations is a
Saracens problem and it asks it's
something closer to you know our world
are all quantum correlations in this
commuting operator model so it's some
mathematical model describing quantum
correlations are all of these
approximable and finite dimensions and
you know this complexity question is
there an algorithmic upper bound on MIP
star so these two questions are
equivalent Cyril sins and cons in the
sense that yes answer to one and Paws is
answer to the other and it actually
takes a lot of work to show this
equivalence but a yes answer to steer
Olsen's problem implies a yes answer to
this complexity question if all those
quantum commuting operator correlations
can be approximated in finite dimensions
it implies the existence of an algorithm
to upper bound MIP star like somehow the
quality of the approximation should
depend only on how high or maybe not
I guess it's the same sort of the
Saracens problem it's saying that you
know if you take a commuting correlation
so this is some conditional probability
distribution that's achieved in this
commuting operator framework can you
find a sequence of finite-dimensional
strategies operators that approximate
this arbitrarily well
what I'm confused about is why your
result would say that that's not
possible
because I would have thought it would
depend on whether like maybe you can you
you can get to it but you just can't get
to it
like like the dimension you have to go
to to get close to it is sort of
arbitrarily bad right
right so
so I mean here I'm not even concerned
the complexity I'm just asking for if it
turns out that all of these commuting
correlations could be approximated at
any rate then it would mean there's an
algorithm that can can search over geez
and then there's another algorithm that
provides certificates for upper bounds
and these two will eventually converge
if yeah maybe I well anyhow that you
know through these connections by
proving a sort of an algorithmic no-go
results implies no two Saracens problem
and therefore no two the common betting
let's all say about that you know let me
come back to this this multi pruvit lens
what's really a wonderful conceptual
framework to think about many different
problems I think part of it is it comes
from the fact that there's a very
operational view you know we think of
these provers is trying to do something
and operationally and so on it it's very
useful and the central tool and thinking
about this is really these these
rigidity I think that physically it's
unlikely to be that in this real
physical world real physically
realizable and my PE stars would let you
do REE so what part do you think would
fail first
yeah I don't think it's likely that the
physical world that if I rap on my table
or the two entangled tables in the right
way it'll tell me whether it'll
something will halt
what will fail is some just power
running out of the number of qubits in
the universe or put another way if you
wanted to certify that a computation
halts in time T and what would the
provers have to do they would have to
share log T qubits so T's not too large
and you could run this experiment what
this is saying is that for any T there
could be proves that sure if they had
enough qubits they could prove to you
that it this Turing machine halton time
T but you needed more than just
entanglement you were giving that
provers a lot of power arbitrary power
if I didn't give allow you that how far
would you get as much as what powers
you're willing to give let's say
arbitrary quantum computations but in a
real like a circuit model so is it
really constrained by the amount of
entanglement that's available or is it
constrained by the local power of the
provers so the amount of entanglement
and the amount of power needed for the
provers is roughly the same so T qubits
then they ready polity
there's possible condition on there
lined up because yeah as far as a
nursery will just be questions and then
with a classical thing right you have to
do these can sure okay in terms of
actual client you know what quantum
abilities they need they just need to
measure single qubit X and Z and then do
classical processing you don't have to
do faces changes just just X in
signatures is interesting
say you're willing to assume crypto
assumptions protocol well actually there
was a paper a couple nights ago by Tom
about using just a single prover you can
guess you more like number rounds are
the same but you're shrinking
it seems like you're gonna do something
[Applause]